pour est l'image du cul je me sers pas
actuellement dans le livre que j'ai en
préparation cesson c'est le point
central c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui
résout des pulls et d'un homme qui les
fabriquent
et c'est aussi lisse et le livre entier
et effet comme une puce vin est
construit comme un pull temps chaque
chapitre sera une pièce sur le point de
départ du livre c'est une maison c'est
la description d'une maison mais dans
une petite maison une bonne comme grands
immeubles
voilà donc un des premiers modèles des
premiers exemples du dé ce qui m'a amené
les moins à composer c'est organisé
c'est une maison complètement verrez
toutes ces complications et avec les
pièces oui avec une profondeur apparente
qui est donnée par le fait que ces
pièces ouvre sur d'autres pièces de ce
terrain et puis des scènes je passe non
non moi dont ils voient tous sur une
sorte de tableau qu'un peintre comme ça
pas être derrière peintre qui reste de
peindre ce tableau où il y aurait 7 cet
immeuble ouvert et il y aurait tout
c'est toutes ces pièces toutes ces
petites cases et alors on décrit ce qui
ce qui se passe tous ses pièces voilà la
maison un autre plan de la maison alors
on sait qu'ici il ya une chambre brutale
kelvin vieille femme is innocent bien
étudiants ici une étudiante ici vit dans
une petite chambre peintre qui a peint
tout l'art toute la maison et qui s'est
représenté dans son coin comme dans le
tableau du moyen-âge ici il ya une pièce
qui était occupé par le monsieur qui
fabriquait les puces ici un grand
appartement fait part de monsieur qui
résout les puces en fait on s'apercevra
que toute l'histoire n'est que
l'histoire de ces deux personnages de
nos relations mais ça on le saura
beaucoup plus tard voilà une autre
représentation ça c'est comment on va se
déplacer dans cette maison c'est à dire
que ça va donner l'ordre des chapitres
enfin c'est une ses commandes le lecteur
va céder classement le lecteur les boues
même moi même la travée à travers
différentes pièces de les décrire chaque
fois je me l'écrire ici on est dans
l'escalier entre de votre le quatrième
et cinquième étages et une dame d'une
autre nouveauté qui se dirige vers
l'appartement un communiqué le fait ici
on rentre dans un appartement finances
annonce une autre et vous revenez dans
les pierres jamais on ne revient jamais
on revient dans des pièces qui
appartiennent au même appartement mais
jamais dans le même objectif
le parcours le chemin qu une seule fois
et ce seulement dans les dernières
passes du livre que on aura cette espèce
d'image complète qui expliquera un peu
pourquoi le livre a été écrit ce qu'il
représente pour moi qui expliquera son
titre qui explique